à quel genre d'individu sans nous
confronter
un groupe de criminels aux capacités
inhabituel
utah je veux une piste alors pourquoi ne
pas ouvrir votre parachute de tulle la
jungle et fuir comme tout le monde le
ferai parce que j'aime c'est qu'ils ne
sont pas comme tout le monde monsieur
les auteurs de ces braquages sont des
sportifs de l'extrême ils utilisent
leurs compétences pour déstabiliser la
finance internationale
dans l'action et les peintures
on appelle ebadi
il ya quelques milliards de dollar en or
là en bas vous allez le volet non on va
le libérer
maintenant monteront mois de quel côté
tu es
génie criminel
c'est que des mondes qui jouent avec
leur vie on peut les avoir il me faut
plus de temps
seule vraie loi est celle de la
pesanteur